the opening scene features a 12 year old
girl named Tina who is practicing
gymnastics at her house she is being
filmed by her mother who is a former
figure skater and now an influencer
following this Tina playfully surprises
her father also recording it for their
Vlog afterwards the entire family
gathers in front of the camera to end
their Vlog just then a loud noise from
the window startles them Tina goes to
investigate and finds a feather stuck to
the glass upon opening the window a crow
flies in wreaking havoc in the living
room Tina her father and her younger
brother Matthias attempt to capture the
crow while her mother worries over
expensive glass Decor the crow soon
destroys a chandelier and lands on the
floor at this point Tina comes up with
an idea and covers the bird with a
blanket before capturing it she intends
to release it outside but before she can
her mother asks for the bird and then
snaps its neck mercilessly saddened Tina
disposes of the crow in the trash can
not noticing that it is still moving
later Tina meets her new name neighbor
Rita and her French Bulldog Tina tries
to pet the dog but it reacts
aggressively apologetic Rita explains
that her dog has never acted this way
before sure Bud the same night Tina and
her mother sing a good night song to
Matthias after letting him fall asleep
her mother shows her their latest Vlog
portraying them as a happy Finnish
family while watching Tina tells her
mother about their new neighbor girl who
has invited her to come over however her
mother reminds her of her upcoming
gymnastics competition emphasizing the
need for focus at the stroke of midnight
Tina is awakened by calling sounds she
goes to check the trash can but the crow
is already gone following the noise she
Ventures into the woods and discovers
the severely injured Crow on the ground
she initially tries to help but
inadvertently worsens its condition as a
result she picks up a stone and bashes
its head multiple times putting it out
of its eight moments later she notices
the Crow's egg making her feel guilty
about her action she then brings the egg
home and incubates it underneath a
pillow the next day Pina dedicates
herself to gymnastics practice but she
struggles to do a flip and make a
graceful Landing her coach warns her
that she won't be able to participate in
an upcoming competition unless she
improves after practice genius friends
invite her to hang out but she declines
that a fear of her mother's disapproval
Upon returning home Denia catches her
mother making out with a repair man
named Taro this creates an awkward
situation for all of them so Tina heads
to her room later on her mother walks in
with a new outfit for her upcoming
competition as they Converse her mother
tells her about tarot explaining that
the adults have special friends she also
asks tenia to keep it a secret Tina
feels it is wrong and thinks of talking
with her father but she is unable to
gather enough courage to do so a few
days later Tina is astonished to find
that the egg under her pillow is growing
bigger as a result she cuts open her
teddy bear and stuff the egg inside
during a practice session the following
day she meets Rita who is also a gymnast
like her however she turns out to be
much better than Tina as she does the
flip and even makes a perfect Landing
Dina's mother who is observing this
becomes envious of Rita's skills as a
result she makes teenious stay after
hours to perform the move repeatedly
despite her hands developing blisters
eventually Tina achieves The Landing but
still needs further Improvement in the
evening Tina and her mother are watching
their Vlog when the latter confesses
that she is in love with tarot this
Revelation shocks Tina and she worries
about her father with a saddened face
she returns to a room in sobs placing
her head on the egg which is now gotten
humongous after a while the egg starts
to hatch revealing a claw-like appendage
frightened Tina hides in her closet and
peers through the cracks soon after a
strange skeletal creature resembling a
baby bird emerges and escapes through
the window hearing the sound of
shattering window Tina's father comes to
check in a hurry Tina covers the egg
remnants with her blanket and tells her
father that a large bird had crashed in
the following evening the mysterious
creature reappears in Tina's room
startling her she tries to retreat but
notices that it has sustained an injury
from A Shard of broken glass reluctantly
Tina removes The Shard and covers her
face out of fear soon the creature
reaches out and takes her hand guiding
her to pet it realizing that the
creature poses no harm she befriends it
and names it Ally she proceeds to clean
Ally in the bathtub before allowing it
to sleep beneath her bed while asleep
Tina is awakened by The Barking of
Rita's dog which also Rouses Ally the
creature then leaps out the window and
heads towards the neighbor's house
before long Tina awakens to find Ally on
top of her with the dog's decapitated
body beside her this gruesome sight
makes her throw up but she feels even
more disgusted when Ali starts eating
her vomit this went from weird to
nightmare real quick in the early
morning Tina wraps the dogs lifeless
body in a towel and buries it in the
backyard unbeknownst to her her younger
brother is watching her actions through
the window Matthias complains to their
father who then confronts Tina in her
room however upon noticing blood stains
on her bed sheets he mistakenly assumes
that she has experienced her first
period and leaves her alone later after
school Tina visits a pet store to
purchase some pet food there she meets
her fellow gymnastics friends including
Rita her peers make fun of her for being
shy but Rita extends a friendly hand and
invites Tina to walk home together
during their walk Rita requests Tina's
assistance in putting up missing dog
posters for her lost dog unaware of what
happened Tina returns home with one of
the posters which Matthias notices at
the same time their mother gifts Tina
with a hairbrush but she doesn't have
anything for Matthias this frustrates
the young boy itself he digs up the
dog's corpse and brings it in front of
the parents blaming tenia however their
parents dismiss matthias's claim and
chastise him for his misbehavior enraged
Matthias walks upstairs to his room when
he said suddenly notices a shadow moving
inside tinya's room he then enters her
room wearing a mask as he proceeds to
check under the bed Ally slashes his
mask in fear downstairs Tina begins to
experience a seizure indicating a
psychic connection between her and Ally
the mother goes to check only to
discover Tina's competition outfit torn
off this upsets her as she believes that
the competition isn't important for her
later on Deanie eats the pet food and
vomits it up to feed Ali she also covers
the creature with one of her dresses
you're not fooling anyone Tina that
thing looks during the same night Ali
goes to Tina's mother and leaves its
slimy goo in her hand and thigh this
prompts the mother to wake up and sense
a passing Shadow she grabs a knife and
investigates but she is soon joined by
Matthias who claims that there's a
monster in the house she brushes off his
claim addressing it as a nightmare in
the next scene we see Tina and Rita
practicing their gymnastic routines Rita
performs much better than Tina which
upsets her mother again after practice
Tina's mother offers Rita a ride home
but the girl opts to walk while driving
back tenia suddenly senses that Ali is
about to attack Rita causing her to
panic and request a U-turn meanwhile
Rita feels someone is following her and
begins to run Ally now taking on a more
human-like form launches an attack in a
brutal manner at the same time Tina
suffers from a seizure but her mother
manages to calm her down as soon as they
arrive home Dania rushes to a room only
to discover Ally's malted beak making
her realize that the creature is
beginning to look like a human still not
fooling anyone the next day the family
is having their breakfast when Tina's
mother shares her decision to visit
Tara's house and stay there for a couple
of days she also intends to take Tina
along so that she can relieve her
pre-competition stress later when Tina
and her father are alone at the dining
table he reveals that he knows about her
mother's affair with tarot he says that
he respects his wife's decision but deep
down he is hurt afterwards stina and her
mother arrive at Tara's house and Tina
learned that tarot is a widower with an
infant named helmi the same night Ally
shows up outside Tina's room window she
allows the creature inside where they
share a night's rest together the
following day Tina visits Rita at the
hospital with flowers but she is
horrified by the severity of her
injuries and amputated a left hand my
pet doesn't usually bite I swear she
says when Rita sees Tina she grabs her
hand and begins to scream this terrifies
Tina who then breaks herself free and
escapes back home Tina breaks down in
tears realizing the harm that Ali has
inflicted upon her friend she shouts at
Ally and even slaps herself as a form of
punishment Holly stops and tries to
console her with a comforting hog in the
morning Tina wakes up to discover that
Ali is beginning to look more like her
later on tarot hears Tina coughing in a
room and goes to check on her when the
girl refuses to let him in Taro
forcefully opens the door only to see
Ally feeding on Tina's vomit the
creature gets scared and attacks him
batina closes the door just in time to
prevent him from harm throughout the
incident Tina hides behind the door so
Tara still doesn't know that Ali and
Tina are different the two appear like
twins at this point after a while Tina
walks out and apologizes to tarot for
the incident she shares her decision to
return home so that he doesn't have to
face any more problems tarot graciously
forgives her and suggests that she
discuss her unusual behavior with her
mother in response Tina pleads with him
not to reveal anything to her mother
just then her mother walks in to pick up
Tina for her competition before
departing Pina practices some of her
moves which are still imperfect
witnessing this from other scolds are
urging her to concentrate at the same
time helmi cries and her mother lovingly
attends to the child provoking jealousy
in Tina uh-oh moments later Tina notices
Ali peering through her bedroom window
causing her to fear that Ali might harm
the child while she's away however she
fails to persuade her mother to Take
helmy Along at the competition the
mother records her performance for her
Vlog as Tina begins her routine she
becomes connected to Ali who has
obtained Tara's acts with the intention
of killing helmi sensing the impending
danger Pina deliberately sabotages her
performance resulting in an injury to
her wrist which simultaneously stops
Ally's actions Tara notices Ally but the
creature escapes before he can react as
soon as Tina and her mother return Taro
vents his rage on them he throws them
out of the house telling Tina's mother
that her daughter has a serious problem
with this breakup Tina's mother in a fit
of distress bangs her head against the
steering wheel causing her nose to bleed
she places blame on Tina for shattering
her happiness upon arriving back home
Tina spots Ally outside her window but
this time she prevents it from entering
and instead pushes it away following
this stina goes to her mother's room and
Promises to perform better next time
however her mother is still upset with
her while Tina is in the bathroom her
mother enters her room only to find Ally
in the closet mistaking her for Tina she
brings her out and starts brushing her
hair amidst this she acts accidentally
rips a chunk of Ali's hair out with the
brush in response the creature digs her
sharp nails into the woman's back
hearing the commotion Tina hurries to a
room and separates Ally from her mother
she scolds Ali for its actions and
orders it to leave after the creature
departs Tina finally reveals that all
the recent chaos is because of Ally
despite the shocking Revelation her
mother Embraces Tina and then hands her
a knife urging her to hunt down Ally in
the next scene the mother-daughter Duo
can be seen venturing downstairs in
search of alley along the way they find
Matthias and the father and warn them
about the creature when they return back
to Tina's room the creature Launches on
the mother and pins her down however she
manages to reach her knife and stabs it
in the leg which hurts Tina in parallel
as her mother prepares for a second
attack Tina tries to stop her explaining
that she hatched Ally nevertheless her
mother proceeds with the attack but at
the last second the stupid girl
intervenes and gets herself stabbed
instead collapses onto alley and dies
with her blood entering the creature's
mouth this causes Ally to turn fully
into a human Ali pushes Tina's lifeless
body aside and croaks out one word
mother the movie ends as Ali sits up and
stares at Tina's grieving mother alright
class I expect an essay about this movie
in the comments by next week okay
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching